hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well if you have to
tell somebody in one sentence what the
dialogue meetup is about there would be
a number of different candidates but I
think one of them for many people would
be this question what is virtue that
Socrates keeps on asking me know to try
to answer over and over again and they
never do reach a satisfactory point
towards the added in the part where
they're trying to figure out whether
virtue can be taught there is the
suggestion made by Socrates that virtue
must be wisdom which is not particularly
helpful although you're going to see
similar things happening in some of the
other so-called operatic dialogues
meaning that there isn't any way out
that they don't reach the conclusion
that they want to reach there's an opera
RIA a blockage of the path where they
treat specific virtues here Meno and
Socrates are actually trying to frame
what is not just virtues what is this
virtue or that virtue what is virtue
itself what is the class of things that
are virtue and if we look if we sort of
go through the progression what we see
is Meno has spoken many times about
virtue in his own hometown he gets here
in Socrates says I am NOT virtue as
you know you say you know what it is
tell me what virtue actually is and
someo says well it's easy there is a
virtue for this and virtue for this
every human action every stage of life
every role that a person has has a
virtue you could even go further if you
wanted to and say well animals have
their own virtues like the virtue of it
of a cat is catching mice the virtue of
a dog is barking at intruders and when
it fails to bark that is vicious or
something along those lines right and
Socrates very quickly civ oh that's
that's not what I'm asking you for let
me be really clear I want one virtue and
I want the virtue they give me the
account of virtue to cover all these
sorts of things I don't want to hear
that you know virtue is one thing over
here and over here and over here and
this guy has his virtue and that guy's
got that virtue I don't know what
actually ties all of them together if
I'm talking about health you know health
is not something radically different in
one person from another there's
something that you can actually point to
a common element or essence and then
Meno tries again and poor guy you know
he really is sort of the straight man to
Socrates comedy and he's treated to look
at certain points he brings up specific
very choosy he says well you know
temperance is a virtue justice is a
virtue courage is a virtue piety you
know dignity or great-souled in this
these are all sort of candidates that
the Greeks thought were very important
in our own time whatever I asked my
students about what are the qualities
that you admire and other people they
bring up things like generosity honesty
compassion sense of fairness which we
could talk about as justice and these
are all traits or qualities and sonic
Reche says that's good and you're
actually getting a little bit closer but
you're still not there I want to know
the definition of virtue I want
something that tells me what the essence
of virtue is I want to know what is
common to all of these instances if
you're going to say that courage and
justice and great-souled Ness or dignity
our virtues tell me what actually
connects them together and he's got this
metaphor of bees he says you know if I
wanted to know what a B is you could
point me at this B and this B and this B
but are the bees fundamentally different
from each other or insofar as their bees
don't they have something that's common
to all of them is it possible for you to
point me towards that and here's where
Meno has to say oh now I understand I I
see what you're driving at let me try to
give that to you Socrates and this is
where now you know if you know the sort
of Socrates shuffle you know that
Socrates has gotten going down the path
that he doesn't realize yet is going to
lead to a whole bunch of different
frustrations and Socrates getting
likened to a stingray and befuddle min
and then it's going to hopefully lead
out of that so Meno starts out by
talking and this is again a very typical
common sensical on his own time and
culture Greek way of of understanding
virtue instead of mean I'm talking about
everybody's different virtues he focuses
on one Heath what he thinks is
paradigmatic and it has to do with
directing things well or governing so
he's got this example which is very
typical of the culture of the time the
you know the the free man the person who
actually has property the male should be
out there doing certain things governing
the city well taking care of certain
affairs the the woman should be in the
home ruling the home arranging
everything it all falls under her
Providence and she gets to act you know
as the the determiner in that case as
well there's a very
direct separation and say Athenian
society for example but they both
involve directly thing as well so
whether it's the householder the city
whether it's you know this area or this
area or you can even say like craftsman
you know a good craftsman directs the
the things that he's working with well
or directs the workers who are doing the
the work under him or her well this is a
good candidate
Socrates then says well what does this
really mean let's let's hash this out a
bit more so directing things well how do
you know somebody's directing things
well what is that what does that
actually entail does it entail directing
them justly rightly fairly we could
translate it in any of those ways and me
know says yeah yeah that's that's
exactly what I'm driving at Socrates you
got it now we're done right and Socrates
says well I asked you for what virtue is
and you've given me a virtue justice and
you said that justice is part of or
involved in what it is to be virtuous
that works for justice but how is it
involved in all these other virtues that
you're talking about instead of trying
to like give an account as he perhaps
could have Mino says oh yeah yeah you're
right
I'm confusing a part for the whole and I
can't define the whole if I can't define
the whole by just pointing at examples
it sure isn't going to do any good to
point out one example and say well this
is what it is because there's other
virtues looking true against Socrates so
he uses an expression from one of the
poets again very common thing to do in
ancient Greece to appeal to some sort of
authority in the sense of somebody who
is going to solve the problem or it was
over us but people who are assumed to be
kind of on the ball to have something
intelligent to contribute that's why
they bother copying out their works
because these poets were purveyors of
some sort of nomic wisdom and so the
poet says to rejoice in the fine or the
noble and have power now Socrates says
okay so we got to parse this a bit what
does it actually mean to wish for good
things and to be able to acquire them is
that pretty much what the poet means and
Meno says yeah that that makes sense
and so then Socrates says well now
everybody's virtuous right but doesn't
everybody wish for good things and Meno
you know here he's actually sort of on
the bullish well not everybody I mean
some people actually want bad things
and Socrates goes through this thing and
says well don't they really think that
those bad things are good things they're
under a misconception and that's why
they desire them insofar as they think
that they're good things don't they
you know don't they all wish for that
they may disagree about what actually
counts as real good things but we all do
desire good things so that's common to
all of us that can't be a hallmark of
virtue because we're not all virtuous so
let's turn to the second part being able
to acquire them well you know is it
always good for us to acquire stuff
what about thieves if the thief breaks
into my house while you suppose then
they wouldn't be a thief they'd be a
burglar right and they're stealing my
stuff and my stuff is good stuff you
know good things that's not it that's
not virtue now is it that's not being a
you know excellent in any sort of
important sense that the person is
actually vicious they're breaking into
my house they're greedy they're taking
more than their fair share their unjust
and so Socrates gets me now to recognize
that
not only is a matter of acquiring or
sometimes not acquire sometimes not
acquiring is the right thing but that
it's going to involve the virtues again
so if somebody is acquiring good things
or has the power to acquire good things
its virtuous if they're actually doing
it temperately or justly that means to
be ruled by temperance are ruled by
justice or in accordance with those
which means that they would actually
have to be virtuous or be taking virtue
as the guide and again we find that
there is a circularity to this this
process of definition because we asked
what is it to be virtuous well it's to
behave in accordance with the virtues
we're back to square one and we still
don't know what it is to do to be
virtuous or to have a virtue or whatever
qu is we you know we have plenty of
names we have plenty of candidates for
the virtues but you know you might say
we've got all these candidates lined up
but we don't know where to put them on
stage because we don't know where the
stage should should be placed that's a
fundamental problem and when Socrates
proposes wisdom later on as sort of the
defining quality you know since wisdom
is actually considered to be one of the
virtues that would fall prey to the same
issues that he's pointing out here to
Mino Mino is not smart enough to catch
Socrates actually pulling the same game
that he just criticized Meno for but you
know that's perhaps because Plato wrote
him that way so that we can then catch
it and say wait a second Socrates that
wouldn't cut it either one of the things
that we ought to think about is is Plato
setting the bar too high for being able
to define what virtue is is it is it
necessarily bad in this case I don't
want to say you know that would be
allowable in every case but maybe it's
necessary to actually
do what Minos doing hora Socrates steers
them into doing and saying virtue
involves acting justly virtue involves
acting temperately it involves acting in
accordance with the virtue that doesn't
allow us to define it very well
but it does allow us to develop some
sort of understanding of it that's not
an option that's actually explored as
such in this but it is one that somebody
like Aristotle will make very central to
how we actually acquire virtue how we
come to some understanding of virtue so
in the end it's a wash they try out
different proposals for what could could
you know be the essence what could be
the definition of virtue one of all
virtues have in common and they're never
able to attain it so Socrates says well
we still don't know what virtue is